le poussin monte un peu - whoa Rober arc
vérifie le danger athénien hey meadow
eggy sauce fat hold on Samantha ce
sont mes garçons petite amie à toi est une
petite amie à nous qui sonnait beaucoup moins
bizarre dans ma tête
non Tony t'aime c'est mon fils miles
hmm pas de rancune hein j'essaie de
commencer un nouveau chapitre de ma vie elle
vient avec moi à Miami
pas de speedos je vais à Miami nouvelle ouais
nouvelle maison nouvelle famille je ne veux pas
retourner dans la forêt et  Je ne vais PAS
finir par être lié, revenez sous la forme d'une
caution de la ville et arrêtez une proposition J'ai un plan
oh les quatre mots que la société craint le plus vous
doublez les tracts bonjour whoa qu'est-ce
que c'est oubliez-le après moi vous avez besoin de la
police du ciel
normal  Agence informatique de la 20th Century Fox
Résultat d'entreprise
Alvin Alvin Je suis tamias de beauté pour
une affaire une nuit sans incident
whoa buzzkill
you